bonjour monsieur flahaut merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on entend parler d'une deuxième vague
vous avez dit à nos confrères de
libération que s'il y avait cette
deuxième vague pourrait durer plus
longtemps
pourquoi en fait on n'en sait rien je
suis incapable de prédire pas plus que
personne bien sûr mais on peut regarder
les pandémies du passé et du passé
récent toutes les pandémies de grippe
ont eu deux vagues
est-ce que ce virus se comportera comme
celui de la grippe je n'en sais rien
mais si l'on prend que ce soit la grippe
dite de hong kong c'était en 1969 70
que ce soit la grande grippe espagnole
la deuxième vague a été plus longue
parce que elle a pu courir sur toute la
saison froide depuis le début de
l'automne je dirais jusque à la fin de
l'hiver
donc il est possible et on doit se
préparer comme ça a été dit par la
personne suédoise juste avant on doit se
préparer à l'éventualité d'une seconde
vague qui puisse être assez forte et qui
puisse durer assez longtemps alors on
parle aujourd'hui de redémarrage de
l'épidémie ou d'une probable deuxième
vague et quelle est la différence réelle
entre les deux termes
alors le redémarrage d'une épidémie
serait potentiellement un risque de
seconde vague
donc c'est exactement la même chose on
voit ce redémarrage par exemple à
djibouti qui a des confiner le 18 mai le
24 mai c'était la grande fête de l'aïd
probablement il ya eu un certain nombre
de contacts qui ont généré des chaînes
de transmission à un niveau épidémique
et une seconde vague est arrivée en
arabie saoudite en iran également une
seconde vague est aujourd'hui visible
donc il y à des pays de la planète qui
connaissent de vagues
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui la
situation de la planète n'est pas du
tout vers l'élimination on n'a jamais
déclaré autant de cas de coronavirus que
hier et que les jours précédents le la
première semaine de juin les deux
premières semaines de juin sont vraiment
très très mauvaise en matière de
diffusion de cette expansion de cette
pandémie dans le monde
bien sûr pas en europe en europe on est
vraiment sur la décrue une décrue qui
est prononcée qui est prolongée mais
sous très haute surveillance
alors est-ce que le risque d'une
deuxième vague est aujourd'hui réel
selon vous est ce qu'on a des éléments
aujourd'hui qui nous permettent
d'évaluer ce risque alors c'est tout
dépend si vous parlez de de probabilité
ou si vous parlez de de préparation je
dirais que c'est deux choses différentes
évaluer la probabilité d'une résurgence
d'une seconde vague est extrêmement
difficile
on n'a pas d'expérience sur ce corner
virus on n'a que les expériences
finalement sur la grippe qui ressemble
le plus parce que c'est un virus à
transmission respiratoires
comme je le disais sur la grippe l'idée
qu'il y ait une seconde vague est
presque je dirais consubstantiel du
virus grippal
en revanche pour le chrono virus on ne
sait pas ce qui est important
aujourd'hui c'est de s'y préparer comme
si ça allait revenir
il n'y a pas du tout d'indicateurs de
résurgence aujourd'hui en europe il n'ya
pas il ya des pays qui ne sont pas aussi
en décrue que nous à la pologne la suède
sont des pays qui garde un rythme
soutenu il ya des épidémies en ce moment
dans les mines de fonds chez les
travailleurs des mines de fond de
pologne en particulier qui sont des
lieux clos mal ventilée un peu humide et
un peu frais qui sont typiquement
l'endroit où se développe le mieux ce
coronavirus et pas sur les plages c'est
pas dans dans les espaces verts c'est
véritablement dans des lieux clos mal
ventilée et bien on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui voir de signe particulier de
risque ou de rebond immédiat en tout cas
nous nous faisons que des prévisions
jusqu'à huit jours à l'institut de santé
global des recettes genève avec les
écoles polytechniques suisse et on ne
voit pas aujourd'hui de prévision de
rebond en europe pour le moment
alors pas de prévisions de 2 rebonds en
europe
est ce qu'aujourd'hui en france la
situation est sous contrôle et quels
sont les éléments qui nous permettent de
le dire oui donc comme je disais dans
tous les pays d'europe aujourd'hui dont
j'ai parlé à part la suède et la pologne
la situation est sous contrôle c'est à
dire que la décrue est prononcé la
décrue se poursuit
et je dirais l'augmentation du nombre de
tests qui est fait permet de détecter
assez précocement des clusters et d'en
couper les chaînes de transmission n'a
pas vu aucun de clusters aujourd'hui le
dernier peut être et celui d'arles en ce
moment il ne semble pas être l'objet
d'une extension épidémique même local
donc on a pour l'instant une vigilance
je pense extrêmement forte et donc voilà
cette décrue est très prononcé on a vu
que la france a rapporté 545 cas hier
nouveaux cas donc c'est encore beaucoup
on n'est pas du tout non plus dans un
environnement complètement sûr sécurisé
comme par exemple l'australie ou la
nouvelle-zélande ou même la suisse qui
est qui enregistre un tout petit nombre
de cas on sait qu'aujourd'hui la
communauté scientifique mondiale
travaille sur des traitements sur des
vaccins est ce qu'on pourrait espérer
les voir avant une probable deuxième
vague alors tout dépend cran sera cette
deuxième vague s'il arrive si elle
arrive à l'automne ce sera vraiment trop
juste
à mon avis pour que l'on ait des vaccins
que l'on puisse avoir quelques
possibilités thérapeutiques et qu'on
puisse avoir des résultats d'essais
cliniques montrant l'efficacité de
certaines tentatives therapeutics est
possible qu'un vaccin soit disponible
fabriqué en nombre et s'est
personnellement je n'y crois pas on n'a
jamais vu cela pour faire un vaccin il
faut quand même il ya un temps qu'ils
passent pas très compressible
d'évaluation de la sécurité d'évaluation
de l'efficacité tout ce temps là est
absolument nécessaire ou ne veut pas un
vaccin qui n'aurait pas été bien évaluer
on veut véritablement un vaccin qui soit
tout à fait sécurisé
merci beaucoup antoine flahault d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes professeur et
directeur de l'institut de santé globale
à l'université de genève
merci beaucoup merci au revoir